auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge marco und die an sommer
besuchen in ruanda ihr zukünftiges
fitnessstudio freuen wir waren fertig
ist
ich denke nachher ist kurz aber dass das
netz fertig ich weiß bisher bei auf und
davon
die show was machten sich in kigali auf
die suche nach einem neuen zuhause der
container mit den fitnessgeräten für ihr
studio ließ auf sich warten
mit sack und pack zur familie gaza nach
cuxhaven zu ihrem wasserturm ihr
umbauprojekt erhielt gleich einen ersten
dämpfer
worin waldburger möchte ihre
leidenschaft für hunde zum beruf machen
an der costa blanca plant sie mit ihrem
mann ralf eine hundepension
[Musik]
der wasserturm ist eines der wahrzeichen
von cuxhaven und ganzer stolz von alaba
usa und seiner familie
die auswanderer aus dem emmental haben
den 48 meter hohen turm vor mehr als
einem jahr gekauft
allah und seine frau mirabel haben viel
vor
hier soll ein café entstehen dazu wollen
sie ein bed and breakfast betreiben und
ganz oben im turm selber wohnen noch
stehen sie ganz am anfang ihrer großen
pläne
die capos haben sich auf das projekt mit
dem wasserturm lange vorbereitet vor dem
kauf ließen sie sich von experten
beraten die die durchführbarkeit des
vorhabens bestätigten
doch seit sie in cuxhaven sind tauchen
bei dem 120 jahre alten gebäude immer
wieder neue probleme auf
experten erwarten hier meinte zypries
fordert vom brandschutz ist genau geht
und das gebäude ist sehr komplex für
brandschutz ist einfach und es ist
dieses vergnügen ist der vor ihm und
schumacher meinte neid sondern über
druckten stärker mit dieser großen
brücke passieren dass man das irgendwie
zu entdecken wenn es der parität
bereichert oder auch geguckt hat
irgendwie hätten wir fünf sechs monate
deshalb steht am 21
[Musik]
bis zum golfen liebst du vom vorgänger
erinnert
was nicht
[Musik]
die schweizer haben auch finanziell
vorgesorgt und eine großzügige reserve
budgetiert müssen aber ihr projekt wird
je länger je teurer
in ihrem zeitplan sind sie schon ein
halbes jahr in verzug
es geht es in diesem tempo weiter wird
es lange dauern bis die davoser sind um
wohnen und arbeiten
[Musik]
chorin waldburger und der mann ralf
leben bereits seit drei monaten ihren
auswanderer traum
[Musik]
es ist so schön wenn die eigene orange
hash und sie ist fantastisch
[Musik]
der alte jetzt im anderen baum pflanzt
banane baumwolle untergrund und das
schön es ist winter an der costa blanca
erntezeit für orangen in ihrer alten
heimat in steinebrunn am bodensee ist es
jetzt nass und kalt
zwei häuser einen pool und 6600
quadratmeter land können die
ostschweizer ihr eigen nennen
platz genug für ihre hundepension für
bis zu zwölf tiere die sie hier bauen
wollen die neue heimat der waldburger
ist bei auswanderern sehr beliebt viele
pensionäre aus mitteleuropa lassen sich
hier wegen des milden klimas nieder
potenzielle kunden denn wenn die rentner
nach hause in die ferien fliegen sind
sie froh ihren hund in guten händen zu
wissen
mit hunden arbeiten wollte corinne schon
seit ihrer jugend aus vernunft entschied
sie sich jedoch für eine kaufmännische
ausbildung
ralf verdiente sein geld als chef des
ersatzteillagers in einem autohaus ihr
gesamtes vermögen und die pensionskassen
haben sie in ihr neues leben gesteckt
man alles zu erste group da noch all die
sache dienen eine karotte lytro hornig
monden und der alfeld wirklich zuerst
alles gestrichen ist alles putzt und
super wie viele dies wohl und jetzt zieh
immer bereit
macht schöne frisur jetzt plötzlich
wieder so wie bei dir
weiters haben fast alles was sie sich
erträumten ein schönes haus einen
gepflegten garten und das meer in der
nähe fehlt nur noch die baubewilligung
dann können sie auch mit ihrem
hundehotel starten
[Musik]
ein neues daheim die chance im blick
steht stürmer marco und seine frau die
an haben in kigali nach langer suche ein
haus gefunden
gerade noch rechtzeitig zur
schlüsselübergabe sind auch die möbel
aus der schweiz eingetroffen
zweieinhalb monate waren sie unterwegs
genau zum beispiel oder dass das ist
verlegt wurde und die chance wirklich
meine nie ganz einfach dass das alles
sei ruhig und so montiert ist ja so von
mir hexen historisches wunder das neue
zuhause der chance liegt in einem
ruhigen wohnbezirk
[Musik]
es gibt fünf schlafzimmer jedes mit
einem eigenen bad ideal für besucher aus
der schweiz
die miete von umgerechnet 900 franken
liegt auch im budget alles wie gewünscht
in bar sache sind sie für die nerven
gegangen zum beispiel das noch ruß
gefunden wo ich jetzt wirklich passt
das hätte dass er klappt das mit dem job
beschleunigt sowie deren musikalischen
werke csu nach einer wirtschaft so viel
hat ist nicht mehr weiß wo das sieht
wirklich mitmachen
[Gelächter]
osnabrück jawohl
marco ist maschinenbauingenieur vor der
auswanderung leitete er eine
uhrmacherschule in neuenburg so ist es
geschafft
jetzt möchte die jan endlich ihr projekt
mit dem fitnessclub vorantreiben 21 neue
trampoline haben die chance dafür aus
der schweiz mitgebracht
so lange trainiert er die zkb dem
container und backhaus parat machen so
viel zu tun habe es ist nicht dasselbe
wie sport am morgen so kaputt wie
möglich wenn immer möglich zum sportler
also weil sieht heute wäre wenn die
zunge wie karate die zumba trainerin
muss wieder fit werden bisher studio
eröffnet tropische temperaturen und die
höhe von 1500 meter machen sport nicht
gerade einfacher geht es nach die an
sollen in ein paar wochen bereits zahlen
der kunden die rekurse besuchen
[Musik]
wasser und schiffe prägen cuxhaven
hunderttausende urlauber kommen dafür
jedes jahr hierher an die nordsee beste
voraussetzungen für die geschäftsidee
der nabu saß bis sie den ersten gast im
wasserturm begrüßen können müssen sie
aber zurückstecken
in langnau im emmental bewohnten die
gabe saß ein großes einfamilienhaus in
cuxhaven müssen sie sich mit einer vier
zimmer etagenwohnung begnügen
[Musik]
ehemann allah hat sich ein paar hundert
meter weiter ein atelier angemietet bis
der gästebetrieb im wasserturm läuft ist
die familie auf seinen verdienst aus
seinem alten job angewiesen
momentan bei dem luca was sie aufgaben
widmen masse des freelander und da muss
man mit dem lied beziehungsnetz
schauspieler
[Musik]
der 48 jährige war bis vor ein paar
monaten fest angestellt und leitete die
messe in bern
die sichere anstellung in der schweiz
tauschte er gegen die unsicherheit in
norddeutschland dafür hatte jetzt mehr
freiheiten im job aber auch für sein
hobby er sammelt lego als seine jungs
klein waren hatte begonnen gebraucht
assets aufzukaufen zu sortieren und
weiterzuverkaufen
über die jahre haben sich mehrere
hundert kilo der bunten spielzeug steine
angesammelt das ist natürlich schön bei
der sache und tuspo im web sieht derbe
nicht daran dass sie dadurch noch mehr
hofft und ja die nachfrage groß ist
hessens person aber kein ersatz zu
suchen
und ja auch vielleicht keine möglichkeit
habe metro und das will ich einfach
schaffen für satzteile irgendwelchen
[Musik]
in einem strandhotel absolviert nicola
der ältere sohn unterdessen sein erstes
praktikum damit nur 26 tage
alle zusammen das ist
[Musik]
jannis folgte dem wunsch seiner mutter
neben der schule job er als
zeitungsausträger und besser zu sein
sackgeld auf borneo show mit deiner hand
und so was man hat und so mache
durchgeführt android internet zu mit
einer später tritt er mit dem monitor
scheinen sich schnell eingelebt zu haben
[Musik]
in spanien haben die waldburger post
bekommen ein lärmschutzgutachten noch
von der schweiz aus hatten sie ihren
architekten beauftragt die
baubewilligung für das hundehotel
einzuholen
ja endlich mal die akustik plan
überholens kritisch wie das ist eine
riesen das ist ja alles so spanisch
übersetzer war das alles ganz genau
heißt und sexy das hotel wo mir da
einfach gern höre mir gerne die themen
sind wenn man sie so wie ein baum
oestermann und ganze gebäude das in 50
metern höchste bauen im abstand von vier
meter zum gebäude und die murmel street
hoch dass ich früh sei erstens
lebensqualität denn vor dem hinterher
wenn dir zum kaukasus kommt oder zu
musik der drei meter hoch erfahrung
gesicht qualität verwendet das
eigentlich für stern betrieb also das
heißt sie richten und eine
betriebsgenehmigung hatte ihnen der
architekt noch vor dem kauf des hauses
organisiert die baubewilligung sollte
bald folgen
stutzig machte dass ich von 23 staaten
hinzu da heißt die show gemacht worden
bevor mir dass oscar auftritt
also ich hab meiner schule noch eine
mitteilen dass da was im singen zum
bauherrn
ich bin extra früh ertrag sie unter
sechs euro ethisch wie zahle sieg fällt
damit man dann schnellstmöglich und
loslegt gewähren oder ohne sind und düst
und setzte so als hätte diesmal verbiss
geso bisher bewilligung händler schon
mal fans und auf der rechnung netz
einfach warte also einfach super kunden
befinden irgendwoher für waldburger es
ist klar sie müssen dringend mit ihrem
architekten besprechen
[Musik]
in der ruandischen hauptstadt kigali
machen sich die chance auf den weg in
ihr neues fitnessstudio
die strecke wird die an bald täglich
fahren ohne den sonst üblichen staus
sind es nur zehn minuten
wochenlang suchte die 49-jährige nach
bezahlbaren räumlichkeiten vier bis fünf
millionen pro monat über 5000 maximal
190 230 dollar wolle aber es ist immer
noch viel zu viel
jetzt hat die an über eine maklerin eine
günstigere alternative gefunden
die räumlichkeiten für das fitnessstudio
befinden sich dort wo man sie nicht
erwartet
im hinteren teil einer bar hier wird
alles komplett umgebaut
extra für die bedürfnisse der show was
die arbeiter müssen wenn der versetzen
die decke neu machen sowie duschen und
toiletten ein baustellen baustelle pur
und das alles in kürzester zeit schon in
drei wochen heißt es könnten chance
eröffnen
ich freue mich waren fertig ist
ich denke nachricht kurz aber dass das
netz vergisst nie 1000 dollar kosten die
räume im monat vermieter hamlet kümmert
sich um den umbau die chance haben ihm
dafür vier monatsmieten im voraus
bezahlt auch den zugang zum studio wird
hamlet neu machen
dazu muss er mehrere wände durchbrechen
bis hin zur straße nach glocksee hat
aber wir kennen den zentralen dritte
zwischenzeit müsse das größte schicht
eigentlich lieber an einen ort gut
trainieren was nicht passiert dass sie
dran sind das ist nicht so dran
der wanderer die sache okay
wünschen ärger ja ok naja das ist okay
okay
bevor die vierte gurke oder probe
schwierig zu finden
vermieter hamlet führt sie nicht etwa in
den baumarkt sondern in einen laden für
kinder bedarf harry wohnung war plastik
so dies kann man auch mit worte benutzen
aber vermied es ist zu weich mit der
zither probleme mit class muss nicht so
hart wie hier aber auch nicht so weit
die an ist noch nicht zufrieden
vermieter hamlet muss weiter suchen
[Musik]
der wasserturm in cuxhaven wartet weiter
darauf mit neuem leben erfüllt zu werden
wir müssen vorwärts machen es geht auch
um die baugenehmigung die müssen wir ein
reiches aller und mirabel kommen mit
ihrem vorhaben einfach nicht voran
ja das problem ist einfach dass ist
finanziell gar nicht möglich
aber coach 12 jahren
durch die auflagen der behörden wird das
projekt immer teurer
trotz allem tabus sind nach wie vor fest
von ihrem plan überzeugt
er ist so niedrig wie das größte ist das
machen versprach er visiert das
bezirkliche gespräche zahlen
ausbauen will das ist
[Musik]
an der costa blanca haben chorin und
ralf einen termin mit ihrem architekten
vereinbart
seit monaten warten die ostschweizer auf
die baubewilligung die ihnen vor dem
kauf der liegenschaft zugesichert wurde
konnte architekt roosters projekttag
marktgröße sohn lothar bock seite
schreibt problem zum neuaufbau
damit werden muss sich um einfach diese
frage stellt hat das mit einmal klar ist
wo liegt dieses projekt wenn ich sie
geworden
das dokument sehen wenn sie setzten die
tänze letzte sie es nur zeigen erreichen
innerhalb serie innerhalb der möchte man
das gern gesehen mit dem stempel in
guter schrift wenn sie ist das noch
keine antwort denn so einfach denn
irgendwie so gut wie
letzte seite finger zum abschluss und
ohne biss und zu mal frauen mit worden
ralf ist nervös er möchte den termin
gerne hinter sich bringen
aber das dauert wie so oft in spanien
architekt oben hat seinen bautechniker
filippe mitgebracht mit euch besprechen
wie im moment
der stand von unserem projekt ist weil
felipe hatte ralf letztes mal die
papiere gegeben
und da haben wir gesehen
dieses projekt ist vom 23 august
letztes jahr wurde natürlich alles
machen bevor der beschreibung von lothar
vertrag genau so kleemann ganzen ist
wegen dem datum
ja es ist zum 23 auf dem augustiner und
und wir haben bis vor zwei wochen das
noch nie gesehen nach dem plan hier
müssen wir eine drei meter hohe mauer
bauen
im prinzip aber all das müssen wir das
steht hier so auch noch nach gesetz
wurde
wir sind das alles richtig sehen dass
ich natürlich ein bisschen kompliziert
weil du bist es weiter und wir sind
gesetzt ist natürlich das gesetz aber
das sind keine mathematik
das sind und dass wir einmal das ist das
einfachste das nächste und das billigste
das ist eine lösung
das passt mit den asean gesetzt das ist
nur vor dem medium zu bekommen
ralf und gar in scheinen verunsichert
erzählt ihnen architekt robert
tatsächlich die wahrheit oder hält er
sie nur hin der gemeinde das alles
geprüft das wissen wir nicht doch die
haben ja von einem zoo im moment wie
martin bis wir eine handliche freundes
haut 67 8 monate und das muss nicht nach
unten gehen
sie ist hier ja man muss immer geduld
haben wir haben einige sachen machen
muchas gracias
so langsam realisieren die waldburger
sie sind ihrem architekten und der
spanischen bürokratie ausgeliefert ob es
ihnen gefällt oder nicht
[Musik]
marco sätze zu dieser zeit in der
schweiz längst in seinem büro in der
uhrmacherschule in rohren da geht der
51-jährige den tag etwas lockerer an
seine frau die an ist hingegen schon
wieder unterwegs in sachen fitness
studio sie hat einen termin bei ihrer
umzugs firma noch immer lagern hier die
18 fitnessgeräte die chance in container
aus der schweiz mitgebracht haben die
geräte hat die hre vom fitness club
übernommen bei dem sie als zumba
trainerin tätig war
jeder tag an dem die geräte hier länger
stehen kostet thomas bares geld und wo
die besitze vor die raum vor fitness
dort wo wieder unsere sache können das
weil wir sehr schnell dass er fertig ist
stromberg seit stadttor zahlen
wie sollen dort bei ihm sache wäre
solange die chance mit dem fitnessstudio
kein geld verdienen müssen sie die
kosten besonders im blick behalten
[Musik]
auch in norddeutschland gilt wer
auswandert muss durchhaltevermögen
besitzen und darf sich von rückschlägen
nicht unterkriegen lassen
kaum jemand weiß das besser als familie
gab es bis es mit dem wasserturm
weitergeht wollen anna und mirabellen
eine weitere idee vorantreiben
ein oldtimer aus frankreich ein citroën
hybrid4 haben die beiden ein faible für
alte dinge chance
das media der florida von wo er seinen
körper macht und helfer zum beispiel
rufe wie der ausspruch tut es mich auf
ich hoffe ich mache für die wahl
[Musik]
sagte einfach langsam herum die
kaffeemaschine und hero besser bestückt
aber es muss im laufe der hybrid4 auch
gute nerven
[Musik]
warten zu müssen ist auch für ralf und
corinne waldburger ein zustand den sie
nicht gewohnt sind
seit sie sich im jahr 2017 kennengelernt
haben ging es im eiltempo durch ihr
gemeinsames leben nach einem jahr
zusammen ziehen dann hochzeit und jetzt
auswandern
daneben ist der hund gesehen und streuen
wo kein halsband dahin könnte und wo
moritz tag sehen dürfen und einfach mit
ein und vielfach ist selber so dass man
englisch meint sehr gekreist die hsk
salzmann dahinter heißt noch nicht dass
du da warst die heilen
[Musik]
anstatt zeit für ausflüge hätten wald
bürgers lieber baustellen stress die
beiden wollten eigentlich kurz nach
ihrer ankunft in spanien mit ihrer
hundepension loslegen
[Musik]
doch nun schaut es so aus dass es noch
weitere monate dauert bis sie überhaupt
die baubewilligung bekommen
die steht folgerichtig weiß wie die
finanzielle situation ist total sind die
fragen schon wieder rechnen ja auch
kosten da überhaupt darüber damit machen
einzelzimmer und meiner familie und mir
sind ja im plan sein egal ob es schmeckt
wunderbar
[Musik]
wann sie ihr hundehotel eröffnen können
steht zwar noch in den sternen aber
visitenkarten wollen sie sich dennoch
schon mal machen lassen
[Musik]
spanisch sprechen müssen sie dafür nicht
die grafiker sind ebenfalls schweizer
die an die costa blanca ausgewandert
sind
so wie hunderte andere diesem gedanke
werk sie dass man das im beruf macht und
der groove klappe und sind da
energieleistung gemälde gefunden
schleiermacher und wie sieht wenn man
beides nichts größer zu machen
zum die idee vorstellig über mir ein mit
dem die ganze werbung dass man da auf
schritt gespräche will
klar ist so groß wie in sprache
beherrschen
ja klar wo der nieren gefallen
er versteht sich und die haben einen
lauf ski und wird im kreis und andere
möglichkeit zum da so gespräch
auf dem papier sind die waldburger es
nun bestens vorbereitet zumindest auf
denen das sie selber drucken lassen
können
[Musik]
seit sie in horn da ist gibt die an
einmal pro woche zumba unterricht doch
das ist ihm zu wenig sie will mehr
stunden anbieten und in der stadt
bekannter werden
hallo als gerät
bei armin thiemer kabakow gc ist sie
dass sein okay kollegin mit dem
sympathisch und plattdeutsch sie und
jetzt seine eigene holte er luft machen
er wollte aber hier
sie meint sich in der platz vorm
barrieren stunde zu gehen
es ist ja vorstellen
von zumba kursen und dem fitnessstudio
alleine werden schommers aber nicht
leben können
[Musik]
am stadtrand von kigali treibt ihr mann
marco daher ein weiteres projekt voran
er trifft den agronomen barnabas dieser
soll ihn beraten
schon als überlegen sie hier
zitronengras anzupflanzen als
zusätzliche einnahmequelle
das land ist dreieinhalb hektar groß die
chance haben es bereits vor neun jahren
gekauft bisher ließ die anhöhe bohnen
anbauen ohne großen erfolg
zitronengras wird so duftöl gewürzen
oder tee verarbeitet
wenn es gut läuft könnte marco drei bis
viermal im jahr ernten
doch business zum start der auswanderer
marco rund 100000 setzlinge außerdem
müsste er noch gräben und auffangbecken
für das wasser bauen lassen um eine
erosion des bodens zu vermeiden also
investment für für das projekt ist
relativ groß fuest muss ich sagen also
es ist nicht nur das ist wirklich nett
wenn man das würde den sand setzte den
hätte man das problem
zudem muss ich schon genau überlegen ob
das sinn macht mit dem skoda nach genaue
kalkulation beschließt marco in das
zitronengras feld zu investieren
[Musik]
überwiegen überhaupt spaß darsteller und
spanien schätzle und kochen italienisch
chorin und ral farben neuigkeiten in
sachen hundehotel sind so wiesmann wald
gegangen und dann hämmer erfahren dass
diese noch bei gerade da wo es wohnt
unterschriften gesammelt und dann hört
denkt jacke sowie nach bereichen wir ja
gar nicht soviel unterschrift werde das
gar nicht sie und wenn hätte sein anwalt
das blatt mit gevo die unterschrift
darauf sind und den heimatblättern und
blättert weiter
und das sind soviel unterschrift darauf
wo unser nachbar überall zu der rückgang
ist es zum teil zurück gegangen wo
wahnsinnig weit weg wohnt mir
international wo das denn die leute
wohnen und jetzt gefühl die leute gar
nicht dass da überhaupt das grundstück
gibt
die beiden haben mit vielem gerechnet
aber dass nun auch noch die nachbarn zum
problem werden das ist wirklich dicke
post
das sind einfach so für bedenken dass er
wüsste quasi lebensqualität nehmen
diese sind vor schmutzigen seite und
dann nicht nur vor einem nachbau der
bedenke dass eben dieses land nur so
viel wert wenn es in europa auch von
window quasi gut
die hätten auch unterschriften gesammelt
oder also das sind mehrere seiten
ich habe ein komisches gefühl wenn du
noch nicht mal richtig rockig und
wahrscheinlich auch
ich kann schöne startdatum kurzname
nächste woche bei auf und davon geht
familie gruselige mit dem wasserturm
wieder gesammelt erste erfahrungen in
der gastronomie sie retten wenn mein
geschäft und die hat nichts an der costa
blanca versuchen die waldburger kontakt
mit ihren nachbarn aufzunehmen und dann
beginnt auch noch die korona krise
spanien steht stehe ganz andere probleme
haben schon mal in ruanda
der umbau im fitnessstudio kommt zwar
gut voran
doch dann bemerken sie einen
planungsfehler wir hierbleiben vergesse
[Musik]
der umkleidekabine zu machen dass ich
die gerne wieder kommen
[Musik]
story
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge